good morning believe nation today's
message is have a champions mindset over
to you Travis kalanick the champions
mindset I think a lot of people hear the
word champion they think of a famous
sports star you might think of in the US
you might think of a Michael Jordan or
LeBron James going and dunking on
somebody but we think of it differently
and we think of it as well when you get
on the field put everything you have
into it put every ounce of energy you
have on the field
leave nothing on the field and two when
you get knocked down because if you're
an entrepreneur you inevitably you will
be when you see hard times and you get
knocked down get back up and if you keep
putting everything you got into it and
you keep getting back up when you get
knocked down it's almost impossible to
fail cool so what do you think I
absolutely love this topic champions
mindset so I think first thing that
popped in my mind is are you playing not
to lose vs. are you playing to win hmm I
think for so many people and I know
you've interviewed some amazing people
then I'm just you know just started my
podcast just a little while ago we've
had some amazing people on the pattern
that I've seen even just under a hundred
interviews is that the people that
really wanted to do something that
really did something that was you know
that they got some notoriety for that
they went and actually pursued their
passion and made it happen
those people always almost always played
to win they were willing to risk it all
they were willing to put it on the line
for some people that might not be the
answer that they want to hear the maybe
they want to have a more balanced
approach maybe it's about you know you
know feeling like you're ready but the
truth is you're never ready it's never
the perfect time right and so if you're
playing not to lose you're always
playing
it's scared right you're letting fear
beat your mind over everything else but
if you're playing to win you're a little
bit fearless and you don't know what can
happen and that's where you're living in
possibility right that's where some
crazy stuff can happen where people go
oh my god I can't even believe you know
that Bennet took off in the way that it
did hmm
that's that's literally what popped into
my mind I like it I like it it's also
one of the reasons why you know when I
started doing the videos the top ten and
it's Presto's and all that we would only
do entrepreneurs
it was always entrepreneur's my core
audiences entrepreneurs I know a lot of
people listen to your show or
entrepreneurs too and then we started
getting a bunch of requests that were
not entrepreneurs can you do Michael
Jordan now I mean he owns you know sure
businesses and stuff but it's not what
he's necessarily known for or can you do
this soccer player can you do this
musician he use politician or inventor
and at the start I was hesitating
because I'm not sure that these guys are
entrepreneurial enough to be on the
channel what we're looking for
but then in listening to the interviews
they were giving it's all the same stuff
it's all success right like you can
apply the lessons from Michael Jordan or
Beyonce or Messi to your business to be
a better entrepreneur because it's about
having the champions my say it applies
to any area if you look at any industry
whoever's at the top has a Champions
mindset and so I love learning from
people who've had success in different
fields and applying it to to myself my
life my business and so I've been able
to learn from it now this guy Travis
office is an entrepreneur but you can
learn the champions mindset from anybody
who's had success in their respective
fields so the question of the day today
is are you playing not to lose or are
you playing to win I like it leave it
down in the comments we're gonna join in
the discussion thank you guys so much
for watching and have an amazing day
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
this race he'll give me go